my name is
a poem about my fiancee
I'm really rather surprised to be honest
with you osama's getting in front of an
audience
and telling everyone that he wrote this
poem for me his fiancee he's not ashamed
of me it's erasing the rough start we
had and it's like I'm believing in him
again and it feels good it's like this
is it this is the man you know I've been
waiting for
the name of poems as I think of you
as the sun sailing in the sea you sail
into my Dark World you make all the
poems dancing all you the messenger of
the Wolves your words are deeply like
the Bible touched me all my bones my
heart and everything breathe inside me
you the beautiful poem your child has
come to be alive to dance and to sing
[Applause]
thank you awesome thank you so much
I appreciate that that was very touching
I'm so surprised I'm so surprised I
never do something like this before Oh
but you're born for it
thank you this makes me believe but
I read it's good you're ready beautiful
and I feel almost kind of weak like I've
had a shot of cognac or something after
listening to that
and it makes me feel feel
very special I can't do anything you got
that right honey
I'm so nervous that's our very poetry
funds lots of people in public because I
never like you know I never used to this
or even think about this
but as you are with me the missing bus
I can't do it
[Music]
I told you last day that I want to prove
my love to you to everyone so this is
the way I will prove I feel
more hopeful about our future together
when I heard that and you claimed me in
front of all these people and strangers
because I love this truth from now it
will be only actions
[Music]